it takes a lot of work to transform Zoe
saw Donna from All American actress to
other worldly badass the procedure looks
pretty grueling especially if you're
claustrophobic the headcast allows
effects artists to exercise great
attention to detail when designing
gamora's facial appliances and makeup
Prosthetics made from silicone are
sculpted for her cheeks and forehead the
latter of which gives her a new brow
line the pieces take two to three hours
to apply and about 30 to 45 minutes to
remove her prosthetic forehead actually
has a scalp piece that runs underneath
her wig of course the Prosthetics are
only in the beginning as with any paint
job sordana gets multiple complete coats
of primer before makeup artists get down
to the business of Greening her up
completely a green base comes after the
primer followed by three more layers
which are airbrushed on this is done to
get as close as possible to a natural
tone it all meant a grueling five hours
on the makeup chair for the first
guardian's film but only 4 hours for the
follow-up we shaved half an hour from
the first movie so I appreciated that